look at my new T-shirt
did you know that I love Zuko
did you know that I recently only now Learned there's like
actual genuine beef between like
Zuko and Katara and then Aang Katara
like shippers
it's Kaang and Zutara
and like
I legitimately did not realize how much beef there was in the fandom because
I've been a fan of after Last Airbender since I was
you know a child
like a literal child
and I've always been a Zutara girl always
um and I posted like a little TikTok cause I did a rewatch like last month
and I posted a
like a little TikTok edit of the two of them
and ah they were calling me like a colonizer sympathizer in my comments
they were like
what do you mean
you're supporting a relationship between a colonizer and the colonized
I was like
whoa whoa whoa
everyone calm down
everyone calm down whoa
I am just talking about the ship that I've been a fan of
and the thing is
I know it's not cannon
I don't even care if it's cannon or not
like I like making up little things in my brain like whether or not it's cannon
it's cannon here and like Zutara
it doesn't have to be canon
it's canon in here
but I did not realize how much flak people were gonna have
like I get it
Katar and Aang or Canon fine whatever
I can still like Zutara and I'm a little bit of a hater
deal with it sorry
but like oh my god
I love this man
I'm sorry like
I've always been an enemy's lovers kind of girl
I've always loved a redemption archive
always loved an emo little shit even
even those 9 years old right
like I don't understand how y'all will give like more Grace to Iroh
the literal war criminal
then you will to the 16** year old that was abused by his family
like I again
I'm not justifying any of the action
I just
let me like Zutara please
that's the only thing I
I just didn't realize we had so much beef that's all